Dear brothers and sisters, as we watch
what is unfolding today in Gaza, we have
to understand that opposition is
counting on us to lose attention, to
become fatigued, and to move on with the
new cycle. And just as we can't allow
them to dictate our attention, we also
can't allow them to dictate the pace of
our solidarity. And part of that
solidarity is going to be there to
rebuild short-term, long term. I am
proud to give my support, my word of
support to trusted brothers and sisters
in the United Kingdom that have started
awak that have started an endowment to
make sure inshallah that we're there for
the long run. It's going to be long term
and we will not forget our cause and we
will not forget the cause of and we will
not forget our brothers and sisters in
Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Here is a funny clip of a mic drop
moment um of these politicians who are
being bought out. Yes, these individuals
have been bought out by Israel. Israel
is buying them all out. The Epstein
islands using working for Mossad,
getting these famous people to cash them
out, record them. The the Mossad, Israel
and Zionism has been exposed to such an
extent. You can't make this up, guys. If
they gave me a trillion pound um budget
to make something like this to show how
evil Israel is, I couldn't manage to do
it. They've done it themselves. They are
so inherently evil, these Zionists. And
we're going to see the example of one
other sellout, this flipping
intellectual Let's watch for
ourself. Inshallah. Here we go.
>> Wherever I see sectarianism, I say I
don't want that. I want a national
unifying politics which puts Britain
first.
>> You know what? This guy sounds sincere.
He sounds like, you know what? He wants
Britain to be first. Yes. He wants
Britain to be about British. Okay. Would
they allow us to build mosques in Mecca?
All right. Fantastic. He He's on it.
Let's see what he has to say. Come on.
>> Not Pakistan, not Gaza, not any other
foreign policy.
>> He is about Britain. He's made it not
Pakistan, no Gaza, nowhere else. It's
about Britain. He This man is a patriot.
He is a patriot. Like Tommy Robert said,
>> Britain first.
>> Britain first. It is. He said it again.
This man is clear as crystal. There's
nothing else that could be said. He
knows what he's talking about. He knows
what he wants. That's right.
Not Israel.
>> Well, not Israel. The media has just
been talking about Israel and the idea.
>> Oh, whoa. One second. Whoa, whoa, what
happened there? I mean, what about
Israel? What about not Israel? I mean,
be consistent. Not Pakistan, not Gaza,
not this, not that. I'm sure Israel is a
foreign country as well. Foreign
government, foreign agency. No, no,
what's the disappointment face going on?
I don't know what's going on. Let's
watch it for the last four or five days.
That's what they talk about. You
wouldn't think that high streets in this
country are on the, you know, are on the
way down or public services aren't doing
well or people are struggling with their
bills.
>> Who cares, mate? Israel first. Who
cares? What happened, my friend? The mic
drop. Look how his face drops at that
fact. The guy is working for Israel,
bro. He doesn't even care about his own
countrymen. The poor people, British
children going to school without food to
eat, poverty. But who cares? Israel
first. The United uh United Israel. Yes.
Like United States of Israel.
>> I hear so much about Israel. Israel is a
very close ally. Well, until recently it
was
>> Oh, where did we hear that first? The
justification is what? They're our ally.
They're your children. They're my
They're our ally. That That's what
matters.
>> A very close ally of the United Kingdom.
We should look after our allies.
Unfortunately,
>> no, we shouldn't.
>> Unfortunately,
>> we should look we should look after
Britain.
>> That guy, the interviewer, is more of a
patriot than this guy. We should look
after ally. Your allies robbing you.
robbing you, has infiltrated your
system, is got is is is literally
rinsing you out, robbing you dry and
nope, it comes first. You know why? Cuz
it's his money. He's not saying this
because he cares, you know. It's because
they are paying him. He's on the
payroll.
>> Unfortunately, Israel no longer feels
that we are a reliable ally thanks to
the Labor government.
>> The point of politicians in the UK
should be to look out for the UK. That's
it. That's something by the way that the
right always used to say, and I used to
look at them as somebody left going, you
know, I think they've got a point. And
large parts the right math. You've just
gone away from that because they just
keep on talking about Israel and Tel a
Viv and the IDF.
>> Exactly. Like Tommy Robinson. Tel a Viv
Tommy. Yeah. He's a good Okay.
There we go. Yes. That's exactly. They
don't care. Tommy don't give a crap
about grooming gangs and this that bull
crap. Do you really think he cares about
that? He cares about the money in his
pocket, the holidays. Somebody when you
guys are little soldiers going and doing
dumb stuff. Yeah, he's there. He cares
about his pocket, man. He don't give a
crap about you British patriot. your
free British uh individuals died in
Gaza. He wasn't laughing. He's the one
who said that he would go and join the
IDF. My friend, go and see. Go there. Go
and see. Go and see what the resistance
does. Go join it, my friend. You coward.
They're making the IDF a protected
characteristic. You You started this by
saying British politicians shouldn't be
talking about other countries. I say,
"Nor Israel." And they say, "No,
actually, no, they should be talking
about Israel. You need to make your mind
up."
>> Exactly. But we got exposed so badly. So
badly. And this is what happens in terms
of the truth. Allah has made objective
truth and it will come out. It will come
out at any cost. Subh you can see how
embarrassing it is for him on TV.
>> They should be talking about Israel. I'm
saying I have less of an issue with them
talking about countries that are our
allies
>> than people who are actively trying to
organize politics along sectarian lines,
which is what this independent group is
going to do. Let's be frank. It's going
to be pro Gaza, anti-Israel,
anti-British state, anti-military, pro
Palestine action. It's going to be all
the things that this is that this
country should not really have.
>> Do you know in the last parliament do
you know what percentage of Tory MPs
were members of conservative friends of
Israel?
>> How many?
>> 70%. Be friends of your own
constituency.
>> And subhan Allah I always say this and
subhan Allah subhana says this inah
these wrongdoers these evildoers who are
literally at the cost of money turning a
blind eye to a genocide. Allah says in
the Quran,
Allah says in the Quran, "So that day
the believers will be laughing at the
disbelievers, the hostile ones,
reclining on their couches. is the
believers they will be looking around
have they have not been the disbelievers
paid back for what they used to earn.
Brothers and sisters that day is going
to come where all of these people who
have been sold out by money turning the
blind out to genocide. Allah is the most
just do not ever think they are going to
get away with it ever. Allah is the most
just and the most merciful.
I'm to lie or better